foreign
[Music]
everyone Welcome to our session today
we're going to talk about file store and
NetApp volumes
and I'm going to learn how a clicker
works
you can't use a clicker that's me I'm
Vijay I run product for file Solutions
at Google I'm going to be joined by
kohavit who's my engineering counterpart
so she actually builds everything and
then Sean and we have a special guest
from Salesforce we have lavanya here as
well
all right there we go so a common theme
through this session and a lot of the
sessions is how do customers how do gcp
customers ensure that they have the
right infrastructure to to power their
business and so today we're talking
about file storage but I'd invite all of
you tomorrow there's a spotlight session
I think it's uh 202 is the session
number at 11 45 and the speakers there
will talk about this theme at a much
higher level and look at how do we
optimize at a system level across
compute storage and networking
considering hardware and software to
figure out how we meet all the unique
workloads
requirements and if we do that right we
can optimize for AIML we can optimize
for modern workloads and traditional
Enterprise workloads
so storage challenges you know the
question comes up why is storage tricky
and fundamentally the reason is it's not
one size fits-all lots of applications
do very well with object but there's a
lot that fundamentally need file
protocols and application workloads
within the workload they're not uniformy
they're something like AIML as you guys
know the needs will vary dramatically
and if you're modernizing or you're
migrating you start looking at iops you
look at performance you look at
availability you look at latency and you
end up hey I might need a combination of
different Services across block file and
object
so with that in mind what we're going to
talk about today first is a brand new
product Google Cloud NetApp volumes then
we'll start talking about Ai and we'll
talk about Google storage fuse and a new
product parallel store and then we'll
talk about modern workloads like
Salesforce we'll talk about Enterprise
workloads like VMware and sap and how
file store rounds out the portfolio
so as of Thursday last week we launched
Google Cloud NetApp volumes and this is
well if you're familiar with the NetApp
offering that exists today in the Google
Cloud Marketplace you'll know that was a
very tight collaboration between both
companies this offering is a true Google
product so there's no longer spending
time with both companies you just go
straight to Google and and you get a
true Google product so customers now
single point at contact for sales
billing procurement support and you just
choose NetApp volumes just like you
would any other Google service so it's
fully managed and it's tightly
integrated and unified with the Google
Cloud you use the same apis or the
console to access it the same management
to apis and all the same horizontals and
services that you'd find in any other
storage product like file store or cloud
storage
Rich data management of course built in
as you'd expect you can take the
snapshots you can copy and clone for tev
and Dev purposes and replication is
going to support you when there's either
you know zonal or Regional outages as
well backups are coming later this year
but pretty soon
uh and then one of the big asks that
we've gotten from customers is now here
along with NFS protocol NetApp volumes
provides a SMB Windows protocol as well
along with the Dual protocol the system
is going to scale all the way from two
terabytes to half a petabyte and then
security is baked in by Design including
customer provided encryption keys
so let's dig into the functionality a
little bit there's there are multiple
service levels that you can choose and
consume premium and extreme our GA today
premium comes in at 64 megabits per
terabyte and the extreme offering
actually doubles that both have storage
pools up to half of petabyte and if
you've used the NetApp offering in the
marketplace this is one of a number of
new Concepts this idea of pools so pools
can be provisioned very large and then
they can be carved up and provisioned
into volumes that go as small as 100
gigs so that gives you a lot of
flexibility on how you deploy your
applications and your data pools are
assigned to service level you can move
between them dynamically the SLA three
and a half nines for premium and extreme
and the protocols as we mentioned NFS
SMB and dual protocol as well standard
dirt is coming soon very soon and
that'll come in at 16 megabits per
second and it'll go to all regions after
the initial rollout to the first 14
regions
data protection like we talked about
snapshots copies cross replication and
backups now can be applied to the volume
not just the pool for additional
flexibility
so let's dig into storage for Windows
right so now we have as Google Cloud a
fully managed SMB storage offering to
support Windows workloads and it has all
the Deep Integrations that you have
expected and seen from NetApp over
Decades of experience so multi-channel
for smb3 to really optimize the
performance of your windows VMS and
integration with managed ad the file
serving piece in the cloud obviously is
one big piece it's going to check off
user shares sap vdi all those scenarios
you know but there's also the
opportunity now to serve for remote
locations so that works in the case
where your users are on Prem when your
data is in the cloud or if you want
local caching and local performance you
can use Edge caching which used to be
called Global file cache and in this
scenario your data is in the cloud on
NetApp volumes and you can cache it
across multiple locations in a VM on
VMware where and you can configure the
size and all the active directory stuff
you'd expect kind of gets inherited and
just works seamlessly for you
snapshot also is integrated right into
windows so your windows users can right
click select the previous version grab
what they need without having to file a
ticket and again just integrate it
outside the box
all right next slide
all right and then on the Linux side
right so as we said this is a fully
managed service for NFS including dual
protocols or NFS and SMB with Kerberos
and AD and Rich data protection it's
Dynamic on-demand scaling and strong
security with client managed keys so
with that we will switch to Ai and I'll
I'll hand it to Sean
great thanks Vijay
um you know one of the things that can
you hear me okay is that there right now
it's turned up okay so one of the things
that we've been investing in you heard
Sundar and Thomas talk about this this
morning there's a lot of things with AI
that matter right however a lot of the
training models actually leverage and
want to utilize file systems for their
storage and the training and they can't
be refactored or you don't have time to
refactor that to take advantage of cloud
storage which really supports the large
massive scale multi-petabyte massive
throughput requirements but cloud
storage is not the answer for all
training models and so there's a
condition where you're looking at file
system access to maximize those GPU and
TPU resources instead of waiting for an
extraction on the cloud storage loaded
into the machines and then run it in
your cluster right so you want to
minimize that you'll hear Livonia talk a
little about that as well but one of the
things that we've been doing is really
thinking about this from a portfolio
perspective it is where is NFS storage
make sense where does posix make sense
and where does object storage and fuse
in this case make sense fuse is an Open
Source service that's been available
won't people use that today with cloud
storage to make their buckets mountable
like a file system it's not full file
system but it's a think of it kind of an
in-between and all three of those
scenarios these are ways you can
maximize the GPU and TPU resources
because the data is immediately
available for training now last Thursday
in addition to announcing and launching
Google Cloud NetApp volumes we announced
at cloud storage views this is also
generally available it's also free that
you can now begin to use
cloud storage fuse with your buckets now
you can mount those buckets like file
systems they behave and act just like
you'd expect they're not full file
system semantics so there are some
nuances between using fuse compared to
NFS or posix but it's a way that we have
customers today using object storage
you'll hear code way talk about that in
another session we'll reference at the
end they're using cloud storage fuse for
their Avatar generation app and they
have massive scale as you can imagine
they have millions of users using this
and it's now a supported offering from
Google which does make a difference as
opposed to just rolling your own
we have multiple ways if you can
actually use pre-built images to get
started with cloud storage views and
obviously we support Pi torch and
tensorflow for many of the applications
that need that so this is the one of the
other new file services and I'm using
file Loosely here with fuse that we
introduced in addition to parallel store
so last week was a busy week for us in
the file Solutions area parallel store
is also in preview and new this is based
upon the open source Intel Deus project
this is a parallel file system that
delivers ultra high performance and
ultra low latency for gke workloads as
well as other HPC workloads but in this
case we're focusing on AI this is
something that's actually much higher
performing than other luster scratch
offerings from other competitors it's
also something that delivers that ultra
low latency of 0.3 milliseconds as you
see on the slide that's dramatically
different than object storage or cloud
storage latency of tens of milliseconds
or hundreds of milliseconds right and
this is something that we've also built
in Erasure coating on the back end to
protect that scratch storage space so
the difference here with a parallel file
system is you can scale out the number
of nodes based upon your needs and
performance all nodes have equal access
to the storage and you can get terabytes
per second so throughput with ultra low
latency and that's a very different way
to think about delivering storage for
training models so as you think about
these three different offerings the new
new things are cloud storage views and
parallel store but also file store is
used by many companies you'll hear
Livonia talk about that as well for the
NFS storage this is something if you
think about the different models between
text and audio and video you don't have
to use one storage for all different all
of your training models you can mix and
match the combination that suits your
workload of the profiles whether it be
file size of kilobytes to megabytes is
very well suited for parallel store all
the way to the other end if you're
hundreds of megabytes or gigabytes size
in files that's where object storage
does really well throughput is another
area I mentioned parallel store during
terabytes per second file stores like 25
gigabytes per second but cloud storage
we have customers exceeding 30 terabytes
per second of throughput for their
workloads so it really will Scale based
upon your trading needs and the last
thing I'll mention on this slide is the
IOP side of things right
parallel stores millions of iops cloud
storage not so much millions of iops
much very it's a different workload
right so you have to think about these
across the portfolio of your
requirements which gets into the gke
workloads for file store this is one of
the things that's not new file Source
supported gke for years but what we've
introduced is we've enhanced file store
Enterprise to support multi-shares for
those that are using it today you've
been able to do 100 Gig now you can also
do 10 gig persistent volumes so it's
another way to think about persistent
storage in a different way for
multi-writer applications and whether it
be thousands of PODS or tens of
thousands of PODS they all have equal
access to the same NFS of storage
similar to parallel store right so a
multi-writer use case is one of the
things that NFS and posix does well and
fuse doesn't this also is one of the
things that supports higher availability
for your pod configurations in that if
you have a pod or cluster go down they
all have access to the same storage they
automatically fail over so you can have
that persistent storage across
interruptions as well
file store you'll hear a one more slide
here there are different options between
basic high scale and Enterprise file
store Enterprise delivers a 49 SLA which
means that it's actually synchronously
replicating the data across all three
zones in a given region so if you're
designing your cluster config with
compact placement you can look at
different zones for availability and now
you're protected against a zono outage
for NFS storage
and lastly file store backups is now
supporting right the next quarter will
support gke so there's two different
ways you can protect your gke
environments backup for gke which will
protect the cluster configuration
applications and or data in any
configure any options thereof I'm not
going to go into the details of backup
for gke but that will also protect the
data store and persistent disk file
store backups will just protect the file
store data and that's an interim
solution integration with backup for gke
is on our roadmap but you can at least
now very soon be able to protect entire
instances or if you're using files for
Enterprise backup multiple shares
we've been mostly talking about the
newness in terms of parallel store and
Cloud volumes file store we've also made
some uh additional enhancements to the
packaging and pricing for file store I
mentioned the 10 gig persistent volume
support now for file store Enterprise if
you look at the top we're also renaming
file store High scale to be files for
zonal to correlate to the availability
of the storage service files for
Enterprise we're renaming to file store
Regional to again correlate to the
availability of four nines that we're
delivering through the SLA you can see
the difference is just looking at the
file store columns between pricing
packaging I should mention one I think
the pricing at the bottom is a new
pricing That's the older list price so
there's differences in pricing
availability and capacities and
performance so you can match the
appropriate file store tier to your
application workloads and in some cases
use multiple combinations
then at volumes you see on the second to
the far right different capacity larger
storage pools different protocols that
we that we support with Cloud volumes
now nfs41 SMB there are also other
roadmap items for file store including
backup and nfs41 and you can see on the
far right parallel store so I wanted to
get everybody just a quick perspective
that this is a file solution portfolio
based upon what storage is optimized for
your workload whether it be a modern
workload or an Enterprise workload or an
AI workload these are the solutions that
are really going to support those
various needs
and with that I'd like to introduce uh
and bring up lavanya to share how she
and Salesforce have been using few ke
and file store
so this button right
hello everyone thanks for joining us
today
um I'm going to show you like how we are
at live raising file stores at
Salesforce so we are like small devops
team managing uh Salesforce uh devops
operations for the AI research team
ad Salesforce our AI research team are
building like so many constantly
building like large language models
which are like computer vision natural
language processing models and then AI
for Sciences AI for economics what not
and also the latest generative AI models
for all the for training all these
models we have been using file stores
for more than four years now
and we are
so uh the main advantages I mean the use
case that we are using is like for
training the models we need to store
like massive amounts of data like which
is petabytes of data sometimes and we do
provision multiple instances of file
stores for storing that data
and based on the use case we do select
the type of the file store that is
optimal for that use case
so the advantages that we are getting
here is like they are simple to create
and simple to manage and most of the
file stores are scalable we can either
increase the size or decrease the size
as per our use case and also like we
configured I mean we followed few
techniques to optimize the throughput
like we have provisioned the file stores
and instant file store instances in same
region as the compute instances so that
we can get maximum throughput and also
like you can configure gvinx such as
like network interfaces to get best
performance
so coming to the file store
categories so the one we are mostly
using is the high scale like which is
also named as zonal now so this is the
advantage with this one is like we can
scale up to 100 terabytes and when it is
not in use like you can decrease the
size as well
and uh the further workloads like where
we need more than 10 terabytes of data
size then we go for high scale and also
like when we provision Project Specific
file stores like which are shared by
multiple team members so in that case
these are proven to be like very high
performance
oh
hello okay so uh maybe maybe I will not
wait for the question for the audience
so let me try to to give you a quick
question so it seems where you have ai
workloads so the costs seem like it it
requires you know like you require
endless number of resources of
infrastructure which includes networking
storage compute can you let me know how
does firestore high skill helps you to
reduce the total cost of the project
because at the end of the day you wanted
the work will be done but you don't want
to to to pay so much money of course
yeah yeah actually the high scale or the
costlier version of the file stores but
still it helps to reduce like it helps
to get low latency which helps to reduce
the time for job completion and also uh
like we can reduce the overall cost for
compute resources
thank you
and coming to the basic SSD so we use
this category for workloads which are
like close to 10 TB and then where we
can increment the file store size like
up to 2.5 terabytes at once
the main difference between SSD basic
SSD and zonal is that you can even
reduce the size in high scale whereas
you can you don't have that option in
basic SSD because of the underlying
Hardware but throughput wise they both
are almost same
and maybe I will have a small comment
here so we have just expanded files or
zonal capacity to cover one to ten
terabytes range so in that case uh so
file store Enterprise or high scale
could also be an option so this is a
fast solution so definitely you can see
it as a menu of solutions for your needs
I of course I think that would be an
awesome solution for our workloads right
now
and coming to the basic HTT we do
maintain like user specific file storage
like in the in those cases like we use
basic HDD where like the performance is
not a bottleneck and uh
by creating like hundreds of terabytes
of data still the file store is the
cheapest cheapest resource that we are
paying for I would say
yeah and and just to say the cheapest
and you know just to think about it you
have so many uh type of workloads and
applications and eventually you know
like a simple NFS protocol a simple NFS
solution supports all of them so it's
kind of like uh um amazing how all these
workloads are needs uh basic
fundamentals of file activities exactly
and coming to the accessing like uh most
of our workloads are gke based and they
need to access like the file stores on
the go so video you create like PV
persistent volumes and persistent volume
claims in user name spaces so that they
can attach their volumes to n number of
pods
so the read read and write many
Advantage comes with these file stores
especially the network file stores which
is so convenient for accessing the file
stores from multiple instances
and coming to the backup of course
backups have to be there to for the
disaster recovery so there are multiple
options for backing up the file stores
so one way is like creating the
snapshots and backups at like periodic
uh time period and then the other option
is utilizing the storage transfer
service which is available in gcp today
you can schedule your jobs and
automatically transfer the data from
NFS volumes to the Google storage
buckets
which is like cost effective way for
backing up the data
so
these are the resources you can check it
out and let me know if you have any
questions
thank you
okay thank you lavanya
um
I I will say just before going to the
Enterprise workloads which are kind of
like obvious but so important for
organization I will say that as an
engineering leader for me uh to lead the
file solution team and get feedback from
customer is one of the most important
values to assimilate in the organization
sometimes you know as Engineers we're
excited of developing like new cool
Technologies but we need to understand
how customers are using these products
and how their benefit and to understand
that sometimes hey maybe it's the cost
that actually impacts the customer if
they want if it will benefit them it's
actually amazed me as in as a young
engineering leader but yes today I
definitely understand the difference
so let's talk a bit about Enterprise
workload so while there are many types
of Enterprise workloads most of them
share similar characteristic the
workloads are critical to the Daily
operation of the business and its
success and what is common that they
have no tolerance to this for disruption
or compromise on data protection or data
correctness they consistently and simply
need to work that's all right so in the
upcoming uh slide I will give you some
kind of two examples of how a faster
Regional offerings supporting
most of the Enterprise workload and how
eventually these workloads are critical
for the customers who are migrating to
the cloud
so the first one is gcbe Google Cloud
VMware engine so this engine helps
customer to migrate to the cloud with
minimal disruption without the need to
converting their virtual environment to
the cloud-specific environment so they
simply need to copy okay the environment
and by that they reduce the time and the
complication of the migration process
and this method is well being used by
our customers
so if I'm talking about file store but
by the way also NetApp so first of all
faster tiers are GCV certified and it
means that when we are using faster
customer can customize our data store
exactly to their needs and there are
several use cases on this slide so they
can either the main two of them is they
can either start from very small
capacity or expanding their storage
without adding any additional of GCV
compute nodes and the Second Use case
that in case of Disaster Recovery the
customer can save cost by running
minimal GCV resources and full storage
and only expand the GCB resources when
recovery is required and
advantages are obvious
effectiveness so as for faster it's
supported for all GCV regions some of
them are not GCS and all the features
like external backup are available in
the GCB use cases
so I mentioned NetApp so NetApp CBS is
also supported GCB North American
regions and upcoming in Q4 Network
volume is going to be GCB supported in
Q4
so let's give example for critical
application and their use in the
important and the importance of their
reliability and high availability
so uh the first one is the shared file
use cases in the cloud so there are many
application and workloads that are
critical to organization whether we are
talking on production systems okay web
servers that are used for the customer
Commerce or shared resources that needs
to spin up more gke nodes to adverse
business needs on demand and there are
more and more okay any Interruption of
this use case can cause severe impact on
the org and we have for that the answer
or file to store architecture that can
be one of the solution to ensure
business availability and data integrity
as Sean already mentioned file store
Enterprises Regional availability that
supports full lines SLA currently
support from 1 to 10 terabyte and soon
it will support uh to uh for 100
terabyte
so every time the application actually
makes a right so the data is being
synchronously replicated in three
different zones so
um
every time we have a Zone outage well
not every time I hope it's rarely so the
application doesn't know about that and
it seamless to the the user and also all
maintenance operations are not
disruptive that this is even further
reducing the risk to the organization
um so let's slide so sap is a great
example for critical business
application that use both for cloud
native customers as well as migrating
customers to the cloud I guess I don't
have to explain how uh the critical uh
and important availability of this set
application to the business
uh
in this architectural dock you can
actually see a three major competent
component that I would like to highlight
that eventually uh um ensuring the
performance and the high availability
for our customers the first one is at
the DB layer we have the Hana DB
workload so we have improved the
efficiency with introducing hyperdisc
extreme new service which is designed
for extreme workload that needs high
iops for DB workloads the availability
of is insured in this case for with the
Hana DB replication
we have application layer the faster
Enterprise for regional availability of
shared files which we already mentioned
in the Ford mirror slide which is
replicated in three zones actually here
you see like two uh um like purple
squares which represent two zones but
actually we support three and lastly
using the backup and the r for off-site
replication in Castle Regional failure
so Google Cloud backup ndr can backup
the DB and the app while file store can
backup the assured files and recover
them in different region in case of a
disaster
so these like the GCV and the sap uh
were like example for critical
application that customers uh uh uses a
file store to support the organization
um
well that was the last slide and the
next I would like to encourage you to
join the next session uh if if your
interest about storage uh so you are
more than welcome
foreign